I want to talk about a genius idea to
end the corona virus pandemic okay this
is not a new idea Donald Trump had this
idea some months ago but he's
revitalizing it here's the idea okay we
want to get rid of all cases ready for
this stop testing don't do a single test
we won't find a single case this is the
idea that Donald Trump again is
suggesting proposing he said this
yesterday during one of those lame
propaganda roundtable events he was
asked about the reality that the United
States is still finding 20,000 or more
new coronavirus cases today states are
reopening some states very unsafely
Arizona Florida Texas North Carolina
California these states are having more
and more and more cases almost every
single day Trump's about to hold a huge
rally in Oklahoma well what if we just
stop testing take a look you just have
to see it to believe it as I said this
morning that's probably the downside of
having good testing as you find a lot of
cases at other countries who don't even
test don't have if you don't test you
don't have any cases if we stop testing
right now would have very few cases if
any but we do we're at a level that mike
is going to talk about that's so high
but we will show more more cases when
other countries have far more cases than
we do they just don't talk about it
so there's actually so much to discuss
here and it's it's kind of a good
opportunity to do a little bit of a
reset in terms of where we are
nationally with coronavirus right now so
first of all remember testing more we'll
find more cases that that's true
generally speaking but testing more over
the long run reduces the spread because
as more people become aware that they
have the disease they stay home if
they're normal people and they don't
give it to other people so yeah in a
sense if you don't do any tests you
don't find any cases but in terms of the
real spread the more testing you do the
better you mitigate the spread of
coronavirus by the way we're still not
testing 500,000 people a day on average
a couple times in the last 10 days we
hit this number 500,000 tests a day we
been talking about needing to be at a
minimum of 500 thousand a day for three
months at this point we're still not
there
okay so reminder we still are not
testing enough then Trump continues to
insist that we test so much we test more
than anybody the u.s. is currently 28th
in testing globally this is per capita
testing this is a really important
detail about testing because one of the
reasons a couple months ago we were like
45th in testing now we're 28th one of
the reasons that we've inched up to 28th
and testing is that there are countries
that no longer need to test because
they've eradicated the virus imagine
that like for example South Korea we
talked about South Korea's early testing
program now the United States is testing
more than South Korea why because South
Korea only ever got to 12,000 total
cases South Korea only ever had 278
deaths total the entire pandemic in
South Korea was 278 deaths so of course
we're now testing more than South Korea
they don't really have a corona virus
pandemic secondly there are other
indicators about how the virus is going
even if you don't test so you could
suppress testing numbers like Trump is
talking about for some period of time
but you have hospitalizations you have
ICU usage and eventually cases turn to
death so even if you don't test
eventually the truth get out it's like
saying if Trump doesn't get himself
tested for an STD he won't test positive
for an STD well that's true but
eventually things are going to start
looking a little bit wrong if you
understand what I'm saying now it's true
that it's harder to find the
hospitalization numbers
most national dashboards include cases
and deaths not hospitalization so you've
got to dig a little bit more but the
data is there one other really bizarre
moment from this Roundtable Trump was
asked about hydroxychloroquine being
taken off of the FDA's emergency use
list it was taken off because it's not
working and Donald Trump very
irresponsibly promoted
a long time trump said when he was asked
about this well there were good reports
about hydroxi from other countries but
then he sort of got irritated with his
own Secretary of Health and Human
Services Alex azar and turned to Alex a
czar and said why don't we have some of
these good reports Alex take a look
great reports coming out of France
coming out of Spain coming out of other
places the only place we don't get
necessarily reports are coming out of
Alex's agency or wherever they come from
I don't understand that Alex what is it
exactly because I have heard I have had
so many people that were so thrilled
with the results from hydroxy so what is
that exactly well your direction we
continue to study especially in earlier
phase so a lot of the data that has come
out that was more negative was people
who were quite ill in the hospital
people that were like seriously yeah
like they weren't gonna make it let's
give a little hydroxy and then they
don't make and they say oh well maybe
the president was wrong
all I know is that we've had some
tremendous reports I've had a lot of
people tell me that they think it saved
their lives you know the one woman whose
affair so this is just great insight
into Donald Trump's lack of
understanding of how medical research
works what randomized controlled trials
are what it means to have a placebo
group and and so on and so forth
double-blind how you actually test
something empirically and arguably even
worse is that people around Trump like
Alex a czar continued to placate Trump
and pretend like well you know yes some
of those tests were on very sick people
but we should really be looking into
hydroxychloroquine on people who aren't
so sick yet prophylactic use they just
keep play Kading trump endlessly now one
more thing to prepare you for the coming
wave of propaganda the Trump
administration is already floating blame
Mexico in terms of you know some of
these states now having spikes our
southern states that share a border with
Mexico Arizona Texas for example so
they're floating blame Mexico for the
spikes no evidence of that by the way
that Mexico is responsible combined with
blame
protesters even though a lot of the
states that had the bigger protests are
places that are not seeing a spike the
protesters mostly wearing masks whereas
in places like Arizona and Texas things
are open almost nobody's wearing masks
and that's really what we should be
looking at so just to prepare you for
the coming propaganda wave make sure
you're following the David Pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show for
more on testing and cases and Trump isms
that continue to plague the country